so
here we have
the main specimen this is what's left of
the oldest meat eating dinosaur that
once roamed the uk a segment of its
spine part of its pelvis and a thigh
bone are all that scientists had to
piece together its movements the
preservation of this material is
actually so great
that you know we can basically see
everything and we also have the left
femur that belongs to the same
individual and we can actually see how
this femur would have fitted together
with the pelvis so we can actually put
it in the large opening in which it
would have articulated the pendrive
milner might have been related to the
t-rex but it looked very different it
would have been about chicken size
essentially a chicken with a very long
tail at the end so the total length
would have been about a meter long the
animal would have been
you know agile would have been walking
on two legs
would have had sharp serrated teeth
would have had a very active lifestyle
and would have probably been eating
anything uh you know that could have
gotten its hands on that wasn't too big
this animal would have lived more than
200 million years ago so that means that
t-rex was closer to us in time
considerably than it would have been to
pendrick the animal we've described now
all of that detail from these fragments
that went unnoticed for so long
the fossils were found inside this
limestone quarry in camarthenshire in
south wales more than 70 years ago but
were misplaced it was only when
paleontologists were discussing the
triassic period that they rediscovered
the fossils tucked away with crocodile
remains it took them a year to
meticulously analyze those tiny bones
so delicate yet dense with information
about the evolution of the world it's a
piece in the jigsaw puzzle that helps us
to understand the evolution of these
dinosaurs and also it really enriches
our understanding of what the
environment in south wales was like 200
million years ago these corridors held
some of nature's biggest secrets from
whale skeletons to dinosaur specimens
now a new discovery joins the history
books just 70 years later than planned
ash and haranag skynys in central london